hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show and the first ever
sheiki's science shout out that was
quite hard to say
and so basically i recently posted on
the discussion part of my channel
that i was thinking of starting a weekly
science news update alongside my usual
videos
and since no one told me it was gonna be
a bad idea
i thought i'd at least try it myself
because i read a lot of content
throughout the week
and often i'd forget majority of what i
read
and so at least by making these videos i
can
at least make some kind of record about
the latest and greatest
science news and when i say science i'm
probably gonna bias it
as most of my videos to biology and
specifically looking at any new aging
cancer neuroscience biotech
crispr related science so
if that's all you're interested in then
hopefully
you'll like this new series of videos
so without further ado in this video
we're going to look at a recent
publication that showed the age
accumulation of
methyl melonic acid and it's linked with
tumor progression
we're going to look at lipid-based
nanoparticles
that enable base editing in fivo and
lastly we'll look at some genetically
modified flies to be released in florida
at the start of next year
so first up is this nature article that
came out
just last week age-induced accumulation
of methylmalonic acid promotes tumor
progression
so the risk of cancer and tumor
development increases with age
but the big question is why and so one
reason could be
as we age we've accumulated more
mutations that could put the cells at
risk of becoming tumorogenic
but there's also other potential reasons
that could explain
this association and so in this study
they showed that metabolic alterations
that occur with age
can produce a systemic environment that
favors the progression and
aggressiveness of tumors
so what they did in the study is they
took
human serum from either young or old
healthy donors and they gave this serum
to different cell lines different cancer
cell lines
and studied the phenotype and genetic
changes within these cells
and what they noticed was that cells
that were given the
older human serum shows pro-metastatic
properties
and so to understand why this was the
case
they looked at the presence of different
metabolites within both the young
and old healthy donor human serum
and what they found was as expected they
saw
decreases in the levels of glutathione
spermadine and glutamine
and alpha-ketoglutarate but they also
saw
consistent increases in the serum of age
donors
and the three metabolites that were
consistently increased were
phosphoenol prorevate which is a
component
of glycolysis quinolinate
and methylmalonic acid and so they
tested each of these individually to see
if any of them on their own
could induce the pro-aggressive effects
seen in these different
cancer cells and they found that the
methyl melanic acid
mma could and say what is
mma so mma is a byproduct of the
metabolism
of branched chain amino acids and
it can be linked to coenzyme a and that
can be converted to succinyl coa
and then that can be fed into the krebs
cycle however this conversion
requires an enzyme that depends on
vitamin b12 as a k
factor and so it's already been pretty
well established that
levels of mma increase in people who
have vitamin b12
deficiency and also vitamin b12 is known
to decrease
during age however they also show that
that isn't likely to be the full
scenario
and so another interesting finding from
this study is the fact that
mma is more effective at causing this
pro-tumerogenic response
at lower concentrations if mma is in a
lipidic structure
because this is transports of mma inside
the cell
so what is mma doing to the cell once
it's inside
well this isn't still fully understood
but what they observed was an
upregulation
of a transcription factor known as sox4
and sox4 is already a marker of poor
prognosis
that contributes to human progression in
a variety of
aggressive cancers and interestingly
sucks for depletion fully abrogated the
ability of mma to promote migratory and
invasive properties
of the cells but it seems likely that
mma is impacting the tgf beta signaling
pathway that is upstream of sox4
to achieve this impact so i'm sure
further studies will elucidate this a
little bit further
but it highlights the importance of
metabolic reprogramming
to the relationship between aging and
cancer
so going on from lipidic structures of
mma
now to functionalized lipid-like
nanoparticles for in-fivo
mrna delivery and base editing so what's
this all about
well many diseases occur due to
a deficiency of a protein for example
hemophilia a can occur due to a lack of
human factor eight
and so in terms of treating these
different diseases it's not trivial just
to be able to
give back a protein neither is it
trivial to be able to edit
the source of the genetic mutation in
the first place
and part of this comes down to the facts
of the difficulty of getting the
materials to the right place
at the right time and so what is
explored in this paper
is the advancement made in the
development of lipids based
nanoparticles
that can carry mrna and so mrna
is the transcript produced from dna
which is the intermediate between dna
and
protein production and so if a cell
receives mrna it can then convert it
into protein
and bypass the the dna stage
and so in the study they screened a
variety of different
functionalized lipid-like nanoparticles
and they found that one of these
compounds
which they referred to as ftd5 was able
to efficiently deliver
long mrnas in this case human factor
8 for the treatment of hemophilia a
and so this was done in mice and so what
they found
was that the delivery of this protein
which enables blood to clot to treat the
symptoms of hemophilia
was able to produce enough of this
factor
within 12 hours to reach 90 percent of
what is seen in normal activity
so as well as this actually being
effective it was also shown that there
was no apparent organ damage within the
mice as well
but the more interesting example that
they used was
a lipid-like nully particle that
contained the components of a base
editor
so they had the mrna encoding the base
editor
and also a single guide rna to target
the base editor
to the desirable sides on the dna
and so this is different so this time
we're not just producing a protein we're
producing a protein which is the base
editor
and the machinery to be able to actually
edit
dna so it's kind of combining two
treatments in one
and this was pretty cool and they show a
high percentage of base editing when
they try to target
the gene pcsk9 the protein encoded by
this gene is important in cholesterol
clearance
and pcsk9 is commonly mutated
and so these sets of experiments
are pretty exciting in terms of
potential therapies in the future
and notably the technology has been
licensed for further clinical
development
so lastly today in this video we're
going to look at
genetically modified mosquitoes that
have been okayed for a first
u.s test flight and so mosquitoes can
carry a variety of different diseases
such as dengue and the most common used
technique
to eliminate outbreaks or bursts of
mosquitoes is by using pesticides and so
not only are pesticides somewhat
ineffective they also have
adverse consequences for other wildlife
and for the environment
but an alternative strategy is to reduce
the rate of reproduction of these
mosquitoes
and one way that you can do that is
through genetic modification
and so there's an english biotech
company known as oxytec
that have developed normal looking male
mosquitoes
that actually contain a gene that they
call a self-limiting gene
that means that when they mate with a
female
any of the female offspring die whilst
only the males
can survive and so also you need the
female
to reproduce to create more offspring
and so if you've only got the males
surviving
you effectively shrink the population
size of these forms of mosquitoes
and the technology that actually enables
this is pretty neat
so this self-limiting gene that they
refer to
is basically a gene that gets expressed
within
only the females and when it gets
expressed
it promotes its own expression and so
you have tons of this one protein within
the cell
and this protein actually binds to the
transcriptional machinery
that basically prevents other genes from
being expressed
and so without all these other essential
genes being expressed
the female larvae actually die before
becoming adults
and so obviously one concern with
genetically modified
organisms is always to safety and
whether or not
the technology can spread to other
organisms but the nature of this
genetically modified
system is such that it is self-limiting
and so it means that it can't establish
in the ecosystem
and it would only target their own
species and moreover
it is environmentally sustainable since
it prevents the use
of chemicals so i guess if all goes to
plan
they will be released in 2021 in florida
keys
so that brings us to the end of these
brief news articles
as i said this is the first time i've
done this i don't know if this is
good bad or whatever but i find it
interesting to
do so that's all i've got to say
so i hope you've learned something and
thanks for listening